foreign
needed to develop the executive presence
to take my leadership to the next level
and Lead really offered that Next Level
Training to be a leader of impact when I
saw the content of the program I said
this is exactly what I need as an
executive to educate myself so that I
can cut through the barrier to get to
the next level
[Music]
my lead cohort was glow
it was diverse and Industry background
experience and it became almost like a
family for me I described the lead
Community as a collaborative Community
helping each other
inspiring each other
encouraging each other
stretching each other they always aim
high and to be the best version of
themselves now I have this network of
support that I know that if I need help
in different areas of my business I have
the contacts the network the people
I've learned to be a better Communicator
I've learned to listen better I've
learned that the core values of a lead
program compassion humility curiosity
and courage really are fundamental
to being a better leader I feel like
without lead I will never have the
network the skills and the knowledge to
start this company and this dream what
lead has really taught me is that you
can be impactful in anything you do
foreign